[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend die
besten chancen kanzler zu werden hat
olaf scholz sagte heute markus söder und
man kann sich vorstellen wie sie in der
cdu zusammenzuckten und das auch noch
kurz vor der gemeinsamen
fraktionssitzung der union die für armin
laschet eh schon eine höchst unangenehme
veranstaltung war für ihn geht es ums
politische überleben die rettung wäre
das kanzleramt geht die union hingegen
in die opposition gibt es im bundestag
nur noch einen wirklich dicken kosten
den des fraktionschefs dafür schaffen so
einige mit den füßen das problem keiner
weiß im moment wie die sache ausgeht
also muss die cdu alle bälle
einschließlich laschet so lange in der
luft halten bis klar ist wie die
künftige bundesregierung aussieht beim
letzten mal hat das was ein halbes jahr
gedauert heute wurde der fraktionschef
gewählt für ein halbes jahr geschafft
berichtet aus berlin
armin laschet im politischen überleben
strudel hier in der unions fraktion
entschuldigt er sich für den
vermasselten wahlkampf kämpft weiter für
jamaika einige stühle neben ihm einer
der in den vergangenen 48 stunden an
laschet seite schien aber nicht ist zwei
stunden vor dieser sitzung hat markus
söder zusammen mit seinem berliner csu
statthalter dobrindt armin laschet
verbal pulverisiert aus diesem
wahlergebnis des klaren platz zwei
bedingt lässt sich nun wirklich kein
regierungsauftrag moralisch legitimieren
wir wissen dass
dies die woche der entscheidungen ist
ist die woche der entscheidungen sowohl
was den politischen kurs anbelangt als
auch was das personal anbelangt kann nur
eines sagen die besten chancen kanzler
zu werden hat derzeit olaf scholz
eindeutig und lars feld hat parallel
erst mal eine andere baustelle wahl des
fraktionschefs der letzte macht posten
in der partei wenn es nichts mit dem
regieren wird da scheint selbst für
nicht antreten er kann sich der
unterstützung nicht sicher sein viele
namen ploppen kürzlich auf märz sparen
rücken kurz vor beginn der
fraktionssitzung ein kompromiss zeichnet
sich ab
bisher liegt mir haben eine bewerbung
vor ralph brinkhaus
ob weitere bewerbungen im laufe der
sitzung kommen kann man nicht
vorhersagen ich bin sehr daran
interessiert dass wir heute eine
harmonische sitzung haben dass wir einer
harmonischen start haben es geht darum
dass wir zeigen dass wir mit dieser
schwierigen situation gut klarkommen und
die schwierige situation ist nicht die
besetzung des fraktionsvorsitzenden
sondern die schwierige situation ist das
wahlergebnis vom sonntag ralph brinkhaus
wird mit 85 prozent gewählt erst mal nur
bis april nächsten jahres länger als
laschet wollte aber immerhin in dieser
frage schafft man die geschlossenheit
bildlich allerdings gruppenbild ohne
parteivorsitzende ich kann ihnen
versichern dass
beide parteivorsitzenden auch ohne
fotobeweis ralph brinkhaus persönlich
gratuliert haben markus söder verlässt
die sitzung wortlos die fraktion hat
einen chef ordnungen dass söder die hat
er heute für sich wieder hergestellt im
versuch armin laschet vor sich
herzutreiben auch in der fraktion gab es
kritik am kanzler kandidaten bis hin zu
einzelnen rücktrittsforderungen das
offene wort habe ich immer geschätzt und
tolles leben war heute die
fraktionssitzung eine die von dem willen
gemeinsam jetzt für unsere positionen
einzustehen geprägt war fehlen darf
liegen werden armin laschet hat auch
heute wieder ordentlich eingesteckt aber
noch steht er
ja und berlin sitzt der alte und wollte
neu gewählte fraktionschef ralph
brinkhaus genannte brinkhaus ja guten
abend sind sie erleichtert dass das
heute so ausgegangen ist hätte auch für
sie ganz anders ausgehen können ja also
ist es gut dass wir geschlossenheit
gezeigt haben und ich denke da muss sich
jeder auch mal ein stück zurück nehmen
das habe ich dann auch gemacht aber
jetzt geben war sehr stabil in die
nächsten monate hinein die fraktion wird
auch ein hort der stabilität in diesen
schwierigen zeiten für uns sagen und
insofern war das heute ein guter tag für
unsere fraktion also man zu diesem guten
tag zu kommen mussten sie sich aber dem
kanzlerkandidaten gegenüber setzen und
sagen die armin ich weiß nicht ich will
dass trotzdem also wir haben gutes
verhältnis zueinander und hin und wieder
sagen wir uns auch dinge ganz offen und
was ich an armin laschet sehr sehr
schätze ist man kann mit ihm sprechen
und man kann mit ihm diskutieren und
dann hinterher zu lang guten gemeinsamen
lösungen kommen und das ist in der
politik sehr sehr wichtig ist dass nach
motor lösung dass hier nur für sechs
monate jetzt als fraktionschef gewählt
worden sind naja also hätte auch für ein
jahr sein können aber wie gesagt es ist
so dass wir momentan in einer
übergangszeit sind und da haben wir
jetzt erstmal block 1 geschlagen und ich
denke mal das ist auch richtig so aber
dieses halbe jahr begründet sicher darin
dass man sie offenbar nicht als
oppositionsführer sieht für den fall der
fälle naja was heißt der offenbar nicht
als oppositionsführer also schauen wir
mal was nach diesem halben jahr ist und
jetzt geht es erstmal darum die fraktion
zu stabilisieren die union insgesamt zu
stabilisieren
und da haben wir genug zu tun hat ein
politiker davon sprechen wir stabiles
sagen für geschlossen das sei weiß man
da ist gar nichts stabil angeschlossen
naja also sagen wir noch mal ganz
ehrlich nach so einem wahlergebnis jetzt
zu sagen boah also wir sind richtig gut
drauf und klasse und wir blicken jetzt
optimistisch in die zukunft das wäre
doch vermessen und dementsprechend war
auch die fraktionssitzung wollte so dass
da natürlich sehr sehr kritisch
hinterfragt worden ist was da passiert
ist was man besser machen kann weil das
kann nicht unser anspruch sein mit knapp
über 24 prozent ins rennen hineinzugehen
und insofern muss man natürlich jetzt
auch eine neue geschlossenheit
geschaffen werden überhaupt keine frage
noch mal zurück auf die
oppositionsführung frage würden sie das
denn sich zutrauen ja natürlich sie
wissen schon dass der oppositionsführer
dann als der stärkste mann manchmal kann
es ja auch eine frau sein jetzt die
stärkste frau der oppositionspartei
angesehen wird mit den entsprechenden
anforderungen an regenzeit redetalent
die leute zusammen zu halten als new
yorker filiale betreten also was würden
sie sagen doch dann bin ich der richtige
also der fraktionsvorsitzende der
größten regierungsfraktion muss im
zweifel auch opposition können und das
habe ich ja die letzten jahre irgendwo
auch hingekriegt das war auch nicht
einfach wir mussten im deutschen
bundestag durch kurve durchbringen und
durch viele krisen und insofern traue
ich mir das zu aber darum geht es ja
jetzt gar nicht jetzt geht es einfach
mal darum dass wir vernünftig durch die
nächsten monate kommt und dass wir uns
gut aufstellen und da haben wir eine
menge zu tun sie werden 49 köpfe weniger
seine der cdu-fraktion was war das für
eine stimmung wie würden sie beschreiben
ja klar also da waren viele kolleginnen
und kollegen da die auch nicht
wiedergewählt worden sind und die sind
natürlich sehr traurig weil die
unglaubliche gekämpft haben weil die
sich jahrelang auch eingebracht haben
und insofern war das heute eine ganz
besondere fraktionssitzung auf der
anderen seite hatten wir auch 49 neue
abgeordnete dabei die stolz wie bolle
waren dass sie jetzt in den deutschen
bundestag reingekommen sind und insofern
auf der einen seite hatte man leute die
lächelten sehr vielen auf der anderen
seite natürlich kolleginnen und kollegen
die sehr traurig waren aber es gab auch
forderungen armin laschet ja also sagen
wir es mal so dass der eine oder andere
kollege oder die ein oder andere
kolleginnen da sehr sehr enttäuscht war
wenn sie ihren wahlkreis verloren hat
das gehört auch dazu dass dann gesagt
wird ja woran hat es denn gelegen aber
überwiegend waren die wortmeldungen
sodass gesagt worden ist mensch wir
müssen jetzt nach vorne schauen wir
haben die politische verantwortung und
diese verantwortung wollen wir
wahrnehmen und deswegen sind wir auch
bereit zu sprechen wir sind auch bereit
zu sprechen mit den liberalen und mit
den grünen ohne ansprüche zu stellen das
ist überhaupt keine frage das können wir
nicht insofern hat markus söder der
absolut recht aber mich würde es freuen
wenn der gespräche stattfinden könnten
weil ich glaube dass eine jamaika
koalition wirklich eine brücke wäre in
einer gesellschaft jedoch sehr sehr
gespalten ist und das haben wir ja auch
gesehen als wahlergebnis er bringt das
stichwort markus söder an er hat ja
heute olaf scholz zu seinem wahlergebnis
ausdrücklich gratuliert warum wir das
oft der union noch keiner gemacht
noch keiner gemacht na ja also das ist
eine geschmackssache wie man dann
gratuliert ich denke wenn der
parteivorsitzende das macht der csu dann
ist das auch in ordnung aber noch ist ja
im grunde genommen alles offen und eins
ist auch klar und das sage ich jetzt
nicht irgendwie aus einer hybris heraus
wir haben keinen klaren sieger dieser
wahl das muss man also auch sagen also
das heißt also dass größten einbußen von
knapp über 25 prozent liegt das ist doch
schon sehr selten also damit
widersprechen sie markus söder ganz
ausdrücklich der hat ja heute gesagt es
gibt einen klaren wahlgewinner und das
ist olaf scholz der kann als er hat die
größten chancen ins kanzleramt sitzen ja
ein wahlgewinner weil er dazu gelegt hat
ganz klar aber es gibt ja jetzt nicht
die überzeugende partei sowie das
jahrelang unter angela merkel der fall
war wo man gesagt hat mir schon klar als
die sind jetzt so weit vorne und die
werden auch den bundeskanzler die
bundeskanzlerin stellen und das ist
jetzt definitiv nicht der fall herr
brinkhaus danken für das gespräch gerne
und dann blicken wir noch auf die csu
perspektive die hatten wir ja gerade
schon angesprochen stefan leifert ist
unser korrespondent in münchen stefan
dass ich sie heute hinstellten als
erster aus der union olaf scholz zum
wahlergebnis gratulierte damit ja auch
indirekt zum wahlsieger aus ruft ist das
nicht schon auch ein ziemlicher hammer
ja was markus söder da heute praktiziert
das ist das maximale abrücken von armin
laschet was unterhalb einer offenen
rücktrittsforderung
überhaupt nur denkbar und möglich ist
eine solche rücktrittsforderung musste
ja auch gar nicht mehr formulieren das
übernehmen in der union ja im moment
genug andere und denen liefert er
natürlich noch mal neue nahrung mit dem
was markus söder heute auf seiner
pressekonferenz in berlin gesagt hat
lässt er armin laschet dastehen als die
losen verlierer und als
realitätsverweigerer und das macht den
spielraum für armin laschet für die
nächsten wochen innerhalb der union aber
auch bei möglichen sondierungsgesprächen
noch mal ein ganzes stückchen kleiner
was bezweckt oder damit
also ein teil dessen was wir da heute
erlebt haben ist sicherlich immer noch
die nicht enden wollende verarbeitung
der niederlage der csu im kampf um die
kanzlerkandidatur nach der wahl herrscht
hier innerhalb der csu natürlich erst
recht eine stimmung von mit markus söder
hätten wir mit sicherheit gewonnen aber
zwei motive richten sich auch nach vorne
das eine ist das motiv dass markus söder
bei allem was jetzt in berlin und
innerhalb der union passiert als der
künftige starke mann in der union
dastehen will egal ob in der opposition
oder in einer koalition das zweite motiv
zielt auf bayern hier sind in zwei
jahren landtagswahlen es gibt viel
kritik auch an markus söder aufgrund des
schlechten abschneidens bei dieser
bundestagswahl knapp über 30 prozent das
ist ein ergebnis was man sich bei der
landtagswahl in zwei jahren nicht
leisten könnte deswegen versucht markus
söder jetzt möglichst viel schuld und
verantwortung für dieses wahlergebnis
bei der cdu und ihren kandidaten ab
zulagen abzulegen wenn hier geht es in
zwei jahren für die csu um die macht in
bayern und damit um alles oder nichts
ist das auch ein bisschen flucht nach
vorne dankeschön für die analyse nach
menschen
eines ist auch klar je mehr konflikte in
der union aufbrechen oder weiter
gepflegt werden desto weniger attraktiv
ist sie als potenzieller
koalitionspartner für fdp und grüne die
ja derzeit mit diskreten vor
sondierungen beginnen christian lindner
das nicht
angeblich ist das erste treffen im
kleinsten kreise schon morgen die
interessante frage wird sein wie viel
beziehungsweise wie wenig man davon
erfährt über kabel hatte hier im heute
journal gestern ja noch mal betont dass
diesmal nicht ständig irgendwas durch
gestochen werden soll ihre jeweiligen
parteien sind aber natürlich sehr
gespannt wie das ganze laufen wird ralf
palik hat sich quer durch die republik
an der basis um gehört bei einer reihe
ortsverbänden von grünen und fdp
sie sind in erster linie an junge haufen
und mächtig stolz auf das erreichte der
fdp ortsverband dresdner westen über
zwölf prozent der stimmen haben sie hier
erhalten obwohl sachsen das gegenteil
einer fdp hochburg ist man ist
selbstbewusst ich finde es schon mal
sehr gut dass wir die ungewöhnliche
situation haben dass nicht die partei
mit den meisten stimmen jetzt erst mal
zur sondierung einladen kann sondern
dass sie erstmal fdp und grüne
unterhalten können was sie sich denn so
vorstellen können weil in dresden
besonders viele junge die fdp gewählt
haben erkennen sie hier gemeinsamkeiten
chancen mit den grünen hoffen auf die
verhandlungsführer das sind immer dann
die player die sich zusammen hinter der
tür auch erstmal auf eine ebene einigen
und da denke ich da ist robert habeck
und christian lindner in der richtigen
spur
königstein im taunus er ein
traditionelleres pflaster der liberal
auch hier trifft sich am abend der fdp
ortsverband auch sie diskutieren über
vor und nachteile einer
regierungsbeteiligung vor allem mit den
grünen skepsis ist herauszuhören aber
auch hoffnung die schnittmengen der
wahlprogramme sind mit der cdu besser
also größer der schnittmenge aber ich
glaube alle warten auf einen wechsel der
politik idee die er habe jetzt geäußert
hat dass es ein gemeinsames projekt
geben muss also man sich zusammen auf
dass es nicht so ist dass jeder sagt
jeder macht irgendwie in den teil
sondern dass man versucht ein
gemeinsames projekt für dieses land zu
formulieren und zu entwickeln da setze
ich große hoffnungen darauf an der
grünen basis fragt man vor allem nach
den grünen kernzielen so auch in
böblingen vor den toren stuttgarts wo
man sich in einem bündnis mit der cdu
mit politischen spagat eigentlich
auskennt hier hat man vor allem die
chancen mit der fdp im blick was sie
will gestalten und wir wollen gestalten
und wie spd will es auch und das ist
eine gute voraussetzung um eine
koalition zu bilden wir sind große
kleine oder kleine große wie auch immer
und wir haben eben die situation dass
wir als kleine partei die so genannten
kellner jetzt quasi uns gemeinsam mit
dem andern kellner dass die fdp ist den
koch aussuchen können und das ist ja
eine völlig andere situation als in den
vergangenen jahren der wille ist da auch
bei den hamburger grünen die am abend
zusammenkamen für sie hier sind die
klimaziele der partei nicht verhandelbar
und immer wieder fragen sie nach der
verlässlichkeit der fdp
das muss jetzt abgelegt werden die
chemie muss irgendwo stimmen dann muss
es ja auch für vier jahre ausreichen der
partnerschaft und das ist genau das
thema also über die themen kann man sich
mit sicherheit irgendwo einigen da weiß
ja auch jeder so schon vorher wo die
roten linien liegen die werden daneben
verhandelt und teilweise wahrscheinlich
auch verschoben aber es geht eben darum
dadurch die vertrauensvoll
zusammenzuarbeiten und themen abzuklären
identität und ziele behalten trotzdem
kompromisse eingehen eine
herausforderung so ist überall zu hören
bei grün und gelb
und jetzt erstmal die nachrichten von
und zunächst zur corona lage in
deutschland die infektionszahlen sind im
vergleich zur vergangenen woche auch
heute rückläufig das robert koch
institut meldet
4171 neue krone fälle innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 493 weniger als vor
einer woche es kamen binnen eines tages
101 todesfälle hin zu sieben tage
incidents sinkt auf
60,3
bei den corona impfungen in deutschland
haben nach angaben von
gesundheitsminister sparen knapp 75
prozent der erwachsenen und ein drittel
der 12 bis 17 jährigen den vollen
impfschutz laut gesundheitsministerium
sind in deutschland noch zu wenige
menschen geimpft noch sei die korona
pandemie nicht überstanden
den usa droht am ende des monats also
schon in einigen tagen ein stillstand
der regierungsgeschäfte ein sogenannter
shutdown die republikaner haben im senat
gegen einen entwurf zur weiteren
finanzierung der regierung und ihrer
arbeit gestimmt streitpunkt ist dabei
vor allem die anhebung der
schuldengrenze teil des paketes sind
auch aufbauhilfen nach naturkatastrophen
ohne einigung werden in der nacht zum
freitag einige us behörden die arbeit
zunächst einstellen
hunderte geflüchtete sind in der nacht
auf der italienischen insel lampedusa
eingetroffen
das fischerboot war mit den mehr als 680
menschen völlig überladen und wurde von
der küstenwache bis in den hafen
eskortiert laut der italienischen
behörden ist es von libyen aus gestartet
regelmäßig landen auf lampedusa boote
mit geflüchteten in letzter zeit jedoch
selten mit so vielen menschen an bord
in großbritannien geht ein gespenst um
ein britischer oppositionspolitiker
nannte es zuletzt lord voldemort der
harry potter bösewicht dessen namen man
eigentlich noch nicht mal aussprechen
darf der lord voldemort der aktuellen
britischen politik ist der praxis und
seine folgen die regierung von boris
johnson nennt sich gründe dafür warum
supermarkt regale leer sind oder sich an
tankstellen lange schlangen bilden wo
eine ursache wird nicht beim namen
genannt
dafür wird jetzt sogar die armee zur
hilfe gerufen
andreas stamm berichtet
was für eine ironie was für ein
schlamassel erklärt trucker terry
silvester kaum noch sprit er steht im
stau vor der nächsten tankstelle
weil kaum noch jemand seinen job machen
will
die vergangenen jahre ist es immer
schlimmer geworden nicht genug fahrer
und die die angefangen haben sind
schnell wieder abgesprungen sie haben
den stress nicht ausgehalten
der job bringe miserabler
arbeitsbedingungen und zeiten mit sich
so terry doch pandemien tbr exit hätten
das fass zum überlaufen gebracht nun
fährt ein land dem sprit hinterher eine
reise die seit fünf tagen auf den langen
schlangen endet hintenanstellen höflich
warten britische tugenden werden
mittlerweile über bord geworfen die
schlange war links und plötzlich war um
die ecke geht es rechts weiter das ist
ihr sehen
ihn zurück in die schlange gewahrt ist
noch keine fünf minuten
gerissene geduldsfaden ändern wenig mehr
als die hälfte der tankstellen in
englands ballungsräumen sitzt komplett
auf dem trockenen
drei tagen suche ich benzin ich habe
vier kleine kinder die ich überall
hinfahren muss
fahrermangel verstärkt durch den dreck
zieht wären wir noch in der eu hätten
wir diese schwierigkeiten nicht
folgen des mangels spürt das land seit
wochen etwa bei lücken im supermarkt
sortiment in der tank krise werden nun
forderungen laut bestimmte berufsgruppen
sollten zuerst an die zapfsäule vielen
ärzten und pflegern geht der sprit aus
aber wir können uns nicht drei stunden
anstellen während patienten warten die
uns brauchen
die reaktion der regierung bis zu 150
armee fahrer könnten aushelfen soll 5000
dreimonats visa für eu trucker geben
wenig verlockend zur
wirtschaftsvertreter fahrer aus europa
werden wohl kaum schlange stehen das ist
ungenügend wir brauchen mehr visa und
die fahrer müssen länger bleiben dürfen
wir leiden an einem mangel an
qualifizierten arbeitskräften
einfach die löhne erhöhen dann wird das
schon so stellt sich premier johnson die
lösung vor und der praxis sei kein
fehler im gegenteil
wir wollen den schwerpunkt darauf legen
ein land mit hohen löhnen hoher
produktivität und hochqualifizierten
jobs zu werden was die menschen dieses
landes nicht mehr wollen ist unsere
probleme mit unkontrollierter
einwanderung zu lösen was wir für 20
jahre oder länger versucht haben
ob es so lange dauert oder überhaupt
möglich ist den fahrermangel auf diese
art zu bekämpfen da streiten die
experten doch einigkeit herrscht der
mangel wird die kommenden monate prägen
und der nächste versorgungsengpass kommt
bestimmt
1/12 macht weiter mit dem blick auf die
finanzmärkte da wurde heute gleich auf
eine reihe von themen geschaut wie es
mit der geldpolitik weiter geht wie sich
die inflations entwickelt ob die
energiepreise steigen so macht ihr heute
der ölpreis zeitweise schlagzeilen frank
wittmann in frankfurt ja ein fass
nordseeöl der sorte brent kostete
erstmals seit drei jahren wieder mehr
als 80 dollar steigenden nachfrage stößt
auf ein schwächelndes angebot
förderausfälle in den usa eine opec die
ebenfalls weniger liefert als sie
eigentlich sollte und so führt die gut
laufende konjunktur auch dazu dass unter
anderem das tanken wieder deutlich
teurer wird aber nicht nur seit
jahresanfang ist auch der gaspreis
bereits um 16 gestiegen das rohöl sogar
um 56 prozent deutlich teurer inzwischen
auch strom und viele lebensmittel und
einen streit um die deutungshoheit wie
lange macht uns dieser preisauftrieb zu
schaffen da ist christine lagarde die
präsidenten der ezb die heute erneut vor
allem nur von einer phase
vorübergehender inflation sprach und da
ist der präsident der amerikanischen
notenbank jerome paul der sich
vorstellen kann dass der inflationsdruck
durchaus länger anhalten könnte ob nun
von kurzer oder längerer dauer die
anleger werden nervöser der dax büßt
heute über 2 prozent ein die börsianer
ahnen was die stunde geschlagen hat zu
stark steigende preise legitimieren die
notenbanken die leitzinsen anzuheben
sparer sagen endlich sie hoffen seit
jahren darauf für unternehmen und
staaten aber würde es bedeuten dass das
kredit aufnehmen das schuldenmachen
künftig wieder teurer werden würde frank
bethmann vielen dank kleine greta ist am
morgen von einem heftigen nachbeben
erschüttert worden die stärke wurde von
den griechischen behörden vorläufig mit
5,3 angegeben bei dem schweren beben
gestern war ein mann ums leben gekommen
mehrere menschen wurden verletzt
zahlreiche häuser sind beschädigt
spaniens regierung hat die vulkan insel
la palma zum katastrophengebiet erklärt
medienberichten zufolge stellte madrid
zudem 10 5 millionen euro soforthilfe
bereit und 600 gebäude wurden von der
fließenden lava masse bereits zerstört
die gesamtschäden belaufen sich
schätzungen zufolge auf mehrere hundert
millionen euro unterdessen wächst die
gefahr dass die lavaströme den atlantik
erreichen
experten befürchten dass so giftige gase
freigesetzt werden könnten
in der alten bundesrepublik waren es vor
allem zwei institutionen die in der
bevölkerung besonders hohes ansehen
genossen geradezu verehrt wurden die
bundesbank so lange es die d mark noch
gab dies inzwischen etwas in den
hintergrund getreten und das
bundesverfassungsgericht die
verfassungsrichter in karlsruhe haben
diesen herausragenden rang nach wie vor
wenn sie auftreten hat das immer auch
etwas feierliches ein gremium wird
besonderer würde auch wenn ihre
entscheidungen nicht jedem gefallen
heute feiert deutschlands höchstes
gericht seinen siebzigsten geburtstag
ein rückblick von christoph schneider
hier nimmt das bundesverfassungsgericht
zunächst seine arbeit auf im prinz max
palais in karlsruhe nach der furchtbaren
ns-herrschaft will die junge
bundesrepublik mit grundgesetz und
bundesverfassungsgericht ein bollwerk
des demokratischen rechtsstaats schaffen
das grundgesetz trägt die handschrift
des nie wieder nie wieder sollten
menschen so entrechtet so erniedrigt
werden können wie es im dritten reich
der fall war und deshalb wurde auch eine
instanz geschaffen das
bundesverfassungsgericht die unabhängig
in letzter instanz sicherstellen soll
dass staatliche gewalt grundrechte der
menschen nicht verletzen kann stark und
unabhängig das ist das
bundesverfassungsgericht als 5 des
verfassungsorgan bis heute und immer
wieder zeigt karlsruhe der politik
grenzen auf grenzen die für politischen
protest sorgen als das höchste deutsche
gericht ein gesetz verwirft dass
kruzifixe in bayerischen klassenzimmern
vorschreibt schäumte der
ministerpräsident vor wut wir werden das
urteil des bundesverfassungsgericht
respektieren aber wir werden es
innerlich inhaltlich nicht akzeptiert
nicht akzeptieren konnte der schwer
kranke helmut feldmann das umstrittene
gesetz zur sterbehilfe er klagte und
bekam recht zur menschenwürde gehöre
auch ein recht auf selbstbestimmtes
sterben sagte das verfassungsgericht im
februar vergangenen jahres den menschen
schwer krank sind leiden und eine
heilung nicht mehr möglich ist und sie
möchten sterben dass das auch
menschenwürdig ist und dann die
bahnbrechende zukunftsentscheidung des
verfassungsgerichts ende april die die
pellwormer familie wachsen zum
klimaschutz erstritt wieder einmal muss
die politik nachbessern künftige rechte
junger menschen müssen heute schon
geschützt werden
letztendlich geht eben um und alles wird
und so alle auch noch viel mehr
betreffen vor allem eben wenn wir jetzt
nicht ausreichend handeln ein viel
beachteter beschluss mit viel lob aber
es gibt auch kritik karlsruhe urteile
nicht einfach nur sondern mache mit
seinen entscheidungen zunehmend mehr
politik in der demokratie müssen wir
davon ausgehen dass es nicht die eine
einzige richtige lösung gibt wir müssen
akzeptieren dass andere andere
vorstellungen haben und das sollten wir
nicht dadurch irgendwie aus der welt zu
schaffen versuchen dass wir bestimmte
expertengremien irgendwie an die
schaltstellen der macht setzen bei aller
kritik das verfassungsgericht mit seinen
16 richterinnen und richtern ist bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern geachtet und
zählt weltweit zu den mächtigsten
gerichten auch nach 70 jahren ist es in
guter verfassung
zu diesem jubiläum gibt es nachher um
0.15 noch eine ausführliche doku dem
titel auftrag gerechtigkeit wie viel
macht hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
und davor um 0 uhr meldet sich
christopher wehrmann mit unserem
heutigen update es morgen auf
wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter für morgen
erwarten wir ein sturmtief es wird
hauptsächlich die nordsee erreichen aber
im vorfeld zieht aus dem süden in der
nacht also hier schauer und gewitter
weiter in den norden aber auch tagsüber
gibt es schauer und dann an der nordsee
kräftiger wind also sturmböen und
schwere sturmböen und dazu viel regen
schauen wir uns mal die details an im
süden also in der nacht schauer und
gewitter die auch ziehen und sich nach
norden verlagern ganz im westen bleibt
es trocken dass bei tiefsten werten von
7 bis 8 grad in den westlichen
mittelgebirgen und 12 grad zum beispiel
im südosten deutschlands morgen am
vormittag dann schauer und gewitter die
aus der nacht weiter in den in den
norden ziehen ganz im norden also
richtung ostsee da bleibt es erst einmal
trocken und auch im südwesten am
nachmittag ändert sich das da wird es
auch im norden schauer und gewitter
geben und dann auch im westen vor allem
an der nordsee wird es dann sehr windig
eben schwere sturmböen sind hier möglich
im südwesten ist es aufgelockert mit
sonnigen abschnitten und die
temperaturen dazu bis 20 grad im
südosten deutschlands deutlich kühler
nach westen mit 13 bis 14 grad die
nächsten tage werden ruhiger vor allem
im norden gibt es noch schauer und an
den küsten viel wind nach süden hin viel
sonnenschein bei 12 bis 17 grad am
donnerstag und am freitag wird es ein
ticken wärmer bis werte von 20 grad ein
schöner abend